we found something a chance maybe use
the stones again so that's gonna use
them to bring everyone back just like
that yeah just like that
ten days we have a chance to take it all
back
it's never about how much we lost
it's about how much we have left
who hasn't been the space
you better not throw up on my ship
of ventures and gay rated pg-13 tickets
on sale now how's it going everybody
it's Warren and of course without fail
we have another new TV spot for Avengers
endgame like I said before we're
probably going to get a trailer every
other day until Avengers end game comes
out or once a day like we have been for
the past few days and they keep giving
us new footage in these TV spots or in
this TV spots case new dialogue along
with new footage but the new scenes and
dialogues that we get in this particular
TV spot actually give us a lot of
information about the sequence of events
that take place in the beginning of
Avengers endgame so I'll break it all
down in this video but first if you're
new to my channel be sure to subscribe
I'm doing a life-sized Infinity Gauntlet
giveaway right now as well as giving
away a glow-in-the-dark painting of Fano
spy globe abaut to enter the giveaway
all you have to do is be subscribed to
my channel like the video and comment
down below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero or villain so this TV
spot starts off with Natasha in Japan
hunting down Clint when she finds them
Hawkeye has already taken on his Ronan
persona and we hear Natasha say some new
dialogue she says we found something a
chance maybe and what she's talking
about is time travel using time travel
to undo the snap this footage of Black
Widow in Japan with her blonde hair is
probably misdirection in reality she
most likely has her red hair in the
scene if we look at this TV spot along
with other TV spots that we've gotten
over the past few days combined with
what she says in this TV spot we found
something a chance maybe we know that
Hawkeye is not there in the very
beginning of the movie when they go and
try to fight Thanos in fact with all of
these TV spots that we've got - in every
scene that Natasha and Clint are in
together natasha has red hair and not
blond hair the trailers are kind of
designed to make you think that Clint
goes with them in the very beginning of
the movie but if you look at the scene
where most of the Avengers are in the
Bennet are flying to fight Thanos you
won't find Clint and Natasha has blond
hair plus rocket is driving in the front
left seat but in the other trailers that
we've gotten Clint is flying in the
front left seat Natasha is in the front
right seat and she has red hair plus we
see her in other scenes aboard the van
entire where she has red hair as well so
Hawkeye is not with the Avengers in the
very beginning when they go and fight
Thanos so what happens is some of the
Avengers go fight Thanos and the very
begin
they lose and then they come back some
time passes by and then ant-man comes
out of the quantum realm goes to the
Avengers headquarters and tells them
about time travel then this is where all
the Avengers start to come back together
we have this scene from the other TV
spot where war machine shows up at the
Avengers headquarters and scares ant-man
and then we have the other scene where
Tony shows up to the headquarters
talking to Steve saying that we're
getting the whole team back so this is
when Natasha goes to Japan to find Clint
he's taken on the Ronan persona because
his family has been dusted Natasha shows
up and says we found something a chance
maybe a chance to bring his family back
and then that's when Clint returns to
the Avengers headquarters and regroups
with the rest of the Avengers then we
have another new scene that shows us a
little bit more about the scene where
the Avengers find out where Thanos is
this time it shows that rocket and
nebula are in fact there so Tony and
nebula have definitely already made it
back at this point because we see nebula
in the scene we then have another new
shot of Natasha training in a recent
interview Scarlett Johansson said that
Natasha is very pissed off so in this
movie we see her super mad about what
Thanos did and that she couldn't stop
him so that's why we see so many
different scenes of her training in
these TV spots she's training for yet
another battle with Thanos and again she
has her red hair in the scene which
means she has probably already fought
Thanos again in the beginning of
Avengers in game and then in the next
scene we see her with a trench coat on
so this is most likely before or after
she goes in gets Hawkeye and then of
course we see Iron Man again in his new
mark 85 Iron Man suit this scene was
shown in other trailers him with his new
energy shield and in the comics Captain
America has an energy shield and in
spider-man homecoming we hear happy
Hogan mention a prototype shield for
Captain America
so perhaps Captain America's new shield
will be an energy shield as well and
that's it for all the new scenes that we
see in this new TV spot let me know what
you think about this in the comments
down below and let me know how excited
you are to see Avengers in-game in seven
days and again I'm giving away a
life-sized Infinity Gauntlet and in
glow-in-the-dark painting of Fano spy
glow by beau you can also find some of
his other work at globe abode com the
link is in the description down below
all you have to do to enter for your
chance to win is be subscribed to my
channel like this video and comment down
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero or villain and again
everyone thanks for putting up with my
voice I'm still a little sick but I hope
to be better soon as always thank you
all so much for
watching woof-woof
[Music]
you
[Music]